en medio de estrictos protocolos
sanitarios el papá francisco celebra
este sábado en el vaticano un
consistorio una ceremonia para la
creación de 13 nuevos cardenales estos
nombramientos son cruciales para la
iglesia católica ya que los cardenales
participan en el cónclave y en los
menores de 80 años votan y eligen al
próximo papá entre los nuevos cardenales
de este año hay prelados de países que
nunca antes habían tenido un cardenal
como brunei y ruanda también hay
religiosos de filipinas italia un
estadounidense la arzobispo de
washington será el primer cardenal
estadounidense afroamericano y dos
latinos el arzobispo de santiago de
chile- y el ex obispo de san cristóbal
de las casas en chiapas en mexico
todos ellos entran a formar parte de la
cúpula de la jerarquía de la iglesia
católica